comme s'ils étaient de vrais ouvriers
équipés de gants de protection ces
enfants très organisés des places de
lourdes pierres leur objectif réussir à
bâtir avant la pause déjeuner une
spirale aromatiques un peu petit instant
couvent est plus grosse et mieux les
petites ça sera la fin ils sont au total
12 stagiaires venus de toute la france a
participé à ce chantier bénévole sur le
site de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet pour eux les grandes
vacances d'été riment avec préservation
du patrimoine
ça doit rester dans l'histoire de france
et bah voila quoi faut entretenir ce
qu'ils ont construit avant un mois ça me
fait découvrir des bâtiments
parce que moi je connais pas trop tous
les bâtiments au monde
l'epa team usa au joli ça fait
historique comme un film de la
préhistoire et qu'on dessert le fait
construite à la fin du xviiie siècle la
bergerie nationale est le lieu idéal
pour apprendre les anciennes techniques
de chantiers comme la maçonnerie ou la
taille de pierre mais aussi pour ces
jeunes apprentis découvrir la vie en
communauté et partager leur
environnement et finalement c'est aussi
le vivre ensemble la vie collective
l'ont fait à manger
hier soir hier après-midi au talent et à
la cueillette sûr qu'il puisse
participer à l'élaboration des repas
qu'on découvre ensemble et légumes qu'on
ait cuisine est en fait finalement
toutes les activités qu'on avait à
l'année elle nous limiter son pouvoir
faire une expérience chantier en général
pour les enfants les enfants sont en
stage jusqu'à la fin de la semaine pour
entretenir et embellir le patrimoine
rambolitains des chantiers dans toute la
région sont proposés jusqu'à la fin de
l'été